« PRO-BLÉ-MA-TIQUE »…
Il est…
problématique,
ce mot.
Pas mal d’élèves ne voient pas très bien
ce qu’il veut dire,
et quelque part ils ont raison :
pourquoi parler
de « problématique » de la dissertation
quand on peut parler de « problème » ?
Eh bien
il y a une petite nuance.
Sur le plan du langage,
le nom féminin « problématique »
est évidemment un dérivé
du nom masculin « problème ».
Et sur le plan des idées,
il y a une petite différence :
le mot « problématique »
ajoute une PRÉCISION
par rapport au mot « problème » :
la multi-dimensionnalité.
Autrement dit,
parler de « problématique »,
plutôt que de « problème »,
c’est présupposer
que le problème intellectuel de la dissertation
est complexe
AU POINT qu’il faille l’envisager
sous divers angles.
Le sens précis du mot « problématique »
repose donc sur l’opposition
entre les problèmes « SIMPLES »,
d’une part,
et les problèmes « COMPLEXES »,
d’autre part.
Par exemple,
savoir si un billet d’avion est cher
est un problème SIMPLE :
il suffit de comparer les prix
pendant cinq minutes sur internet
pour se faire une idée.
En revanche,
savoir si le loisir rend l’homme heureux
est un problème COMPLEXE
au sens où il est impossible
de donner rapidement une réponse tranchée.
La plupart des problèmes de philosophie,
d’histoire,
d’économie,
et caetera
sont des problèmes COMPLEXES.
Trouver la problématique d’une dissertation,
c’est donc trouver le problème intellectuel
COMPLEXE
qu’il faut résoudre,
ce qui est une étape cruciale
de la méthode de la dissertation.
D’ailleurs,
si vous souhaitez connaître
MA méthode de dissertation,
j’ai un cours gratuit de méthodologie
qui vous explique TOUT de A à Z,
avec des schémas et des exemples.
Vous pouvez vous aussi recevoir
mon cours gratuit de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Inscrivez-vous,
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Dans cette vidéo,
je vais vous expliquer comment trouver LOGIQUEMENT
le problématique d’une dissertation,
c’est-à-dire sans avoir besoin d’être
inspiré
ou de connaître son cours par cœur.
Regardez bien jusqu’au bout,
et vous pourrez appliquer ma technique en
trois étapes
DÈS votre prochaine épreuve de dissertation.
Quand on réfléchit pour résoudre un problème
on part toujours de quelque part
puis on déduit d’AUTRES idées
de notre idée de départ.
C’est un peu comme en maths,
où les exercices nous donnent
des hypothèses de départ.
Imaginons, par exemple,
que je doive organiser
un voyage au Japon.
Selon le point de départ de ma réflexion,
le problème ne sera pas le même.
Si je pars sur un coup de tête la semaine
prochaine,
là le problème est :
comment tout organiser
LE PLUS RAPIDEMENT possible
sans se ruiner ?
Mais si je suis passionné par la culture
japonaise,
et si je veux en faire l’expérience dans
le pays même,
là mon problème est :
où aller
et quoi voir au Japon
pour en tirer la MEILLEURE expérience culturelle
?
Autre hypothèse encore :
si je pars en vacances après une période
de travail intense,
là mon problème est :
comment découvrir le Japon
en se REPOSANT le plus possible ?
Je ne vais pas imaginer cinquante situations
différentes,
vous m’avez compris :
le point de départ de la réflexion
permet de définir PRÉCISÉMENT problème.
Que vous souhaitiez organiser un voyage au
Japon,
ou trouver la problématique d’une dissertation,
la mécanique est la MÊME :
vous devez identifier l’idée
qui permet de cibler TRÈS PRÉCISÉMENT
le problème intellectuel que vous avez à
résoudre.
En dissertation,
le point de départ de la réflexion,
c’est l’aspect le plus FRAPPANT du sujet.
C’est une idée SIMPLE
et ÉVIDENTE,
qui est DANS l’énoncé.
Vous lisez l’énoncé,
et quelque chose vous étonne
– vous vous dites que quelque chose ne colle
pas,
et ça vous turlupine :
votre pensée rencontre un obstacle,
il y a un problème.
Et c’est bien normal en dissertation,
parce que la plupart des énoncés
sont justement faits pour éveiller le doute
– les profs les conçoivent
dans cette optique.
Bien sûr,
c’est plus facile avec certains énoncés
qu’avec d’autres,
et comme pour beaucoup de choses dans la vie,
il n’y a pas de recette miracle :
vous devez vous entraîner
pour exercer votre jugement.
Plus vous traitez de sujets de dissertation,
meilleurs vous serez
pour trouver logiquement la problématique.
Maintenant,
voyons comment s’y prendre en pratique
avec un exemple.
Je prends un sujet de philosophie,
parce que ce sont les plus difficiles à problématiser.
« Philosopher, est-ce apprendre à mourir
? »
Quelle est selon vous
l’idée FRAPPANTE dans ce sujet ?
Mettez la vidéo en pause
et prenez quelques minutes pour réfléchir.
C’est bon ?
Allez,
on fait comme si.
Ce qui est frappant quand on lit ce sujet,
c’est l’évocation de la mort.
Déjà,
la mort c’est un peu tabou
dans nos sociétés
— mais surtout,
l’homme ordinaire n’associe pas spontanément
la mort
et la philosophie.
À notre époque,
on considère la philosophie comme une discipline
littéraire
– c’est surtout une matière du bac –
et les philosophes sont des intellectuels
qui écrivent des livres COMPLIQUÉS
dont la mort
n’est pas le thème principal.
Bref,
l’hypothèse proposée par l’énoncé
– philosopher égal apprendre à mourir
–
cette hypothèse doit évidemment nous étonner
:
elle semble à première vue aberrante.
C’est donc ÇA
le point de départ de notre réflexion :
la mort est peut-être
UN thème de la réflexion philosophique,
mais RÉDUIRE l’activité de la philosophie
à l’apprentissage de la mort,
c’est une hypothèse qui paraît RADICALE
– c’est d’ailleurs pour ça que j’utilise
le verbe « réduire ».
Une autre manière de l’expliquer,
c’est de constater
qu’on a du mal à répondre « oui »
à la question
« Philosopher, est-ce apprendre à mourir
? »,
parce que ça disqualifierait
beaucoup de questionnements philosophiques.
Par exemple,
la métaphysique,
qu’on peut définir comme l’étude d’un
ordre de réalités supérieures,
eh bien la métaphysique,
c’est une partie importante de la philosophie
qui ne se réduit pas à la préparation à
la mort.
L’hypothèse proposée par l’énoncé
semble donc très réductrice :
c’est de cette première idée
qu’on va DÉDUIRE le problème intellectuel
à résoudre dans la dissertation.
Normalement,
cette deuxième étape entre guillemets
n’est vraiment pas difficile.
Si je veux partir au Japon dans trois jours,
eh bien j’en déduis que je dois préférer
les solutions les plus rapides
pour organiser mon voyage
– et d’ailleurs je suis prêt à payer
un peu plus cher pour ça.
En dissertation,
le point de départ de la réflexion engendre
souvent
le même type de problèmes,
par exemple :
est-ce qu’un préjugé est pertinent ?
est-ce qu’un contradiction est bien réelle
?
est-ce qu’une exagération apparente
peut être justifiée ?
est-ce qu’un présupposé est pertinent
?
Et il y en a encore d’autres
— vous les découvrirez en vous entraînant
à traiter des sujets.
Reprenons maintenant mon exemple :
« Philosopher, est-ce apprendre à mourir
? »
Mon point de départ,
c’est que l’hypothèse proposée
par ce sujet semble radicale
– comme ça,
on se dit que la philosophie,
ce n’est pas UNIQUEMENT apprendre à mourir.
Du coup,
quel est le problème intellectuel
qui en découle ?
Mettez le vidéo en pause
pour réfléchir quelques instants.
Bon,
ce n’est pas très difficile :
là, le problème
c’est de VÉRIFIER si l’hypothèse
est VRAIMENT aberrante.
Est-ce que ça n’a AUCUN SENS
de réduire la philosophie
à l’apprentissage de la mort,
ou bien est-ce qu’il faut creuser l’hypothèse
?
Bien sûr,
on fait un peu semblant
dans la problématisation,
parce que le BUT de la dissertation,
c’est justement de creuser l’hypothèse
qui paraît aberrante de prime abord.
Donc, à ce stade,
j’ai trouvé le problème intellectuel
à résoudre dans la dissertation,
c’est-à-dire que j’ai l’IDÉE
de la problématique.
Il me reste encore
À LA FORMULER.
J’ai donné beaucoup de cours de méthodologie
de la dissertation,
des milliers d’heures depuis une dizaine
d’années,
et du coup,
c’est par l’expérience,
en faisant des retours à des élèves,
en corrigeant des copies,
que j’ai découvert
la plupart des principes de ma méthode.
Concernant la FORMULATION de la problématique,
c’est toujours le MÊME souvenir précis
qui me revient à l’esprit.
Un de mes élèves m’avait transmis
la correction donnée par son prof,
un plan détaillé de philosophie.
La problématique,
les grandes parties et les arguments
étaient des phrases À RALLONGE
bourrées de vocabulaire philosophique technique.
Je me souviens que j’étais gêné,
parce que j’arrivais pas
à comprendre la problématique
– il fallait que je relise la phrase,
que j’essaie de comprendre ses différentes
parties séparément,
en les prenant une par une.
Bon,
au bout d’une minute,
j’ai fini par comprendre
ce que son prof voulait dire,
et alors j’ai dit à mon élève :
« C’est bien que votre prof vous donne
une correction,
mais…
t’as compris ? »
Et il m’a répondu :
« Non, pas vraiment.
».
Alors,
c’est sûr que
quand on lit une problématique comme ça,
très longue,
bourrée de vocabulaire philosophique,
ça dégage beaucoup d’autorité intellectuelle
– encore plus quand on sait
que c’est l’œuvre d’un prof agrégé.
Mais que va-t-il se passer
si c’est la phrase D’UN ÉLÈVE
et qu’elle est lue à deux cents à l’heure
par un correcteur qui veut se faire une IDÉE
de la qualité de la dissertation
LE PLUS VITE possible ?
Eh bien,
ça va lui prendre la tête,
et il va probablement SACQUER la copie
– or ça,
il ne faut PAS que ça arrive.
Que faut-il faire,
du coup,
pour BIEN FORMULER
la problématique de la dissertation ?
Il faut miser SUR LA CLARTÉ.
C’est déjà important
parce que ça va faciliter la lecture
et la compréhension du correcteur ;
mais c’est aussi important POUR VOUS,
parce qu’il est plus facile de construire
le plan détaillé
avec une problématique CLAIRE.
Eh oui,
parce que la problématique
C’EST le problème intellectuel de la dissertation,
et le plan détaillé,
CE SONT les éléments de réponse
– si le problème est clair,
les solutions le seront probablement aussi.
Alors,
comment faire
pour rédiger une problématique claire ?
Pour faire simple,
je vous conseille de suivre deux règles.
Tout d’abord,
privilégiez les phrases courtes,
parce que plus une phrase est longue,
plus elle risque de perdre le lecteur.
Essayez plus précisément de vous limiter
à un seul verbe conjugué.
Seconde règle :
BANNISSEZ le jargon,
c’est-à-dire les termes techniques
que vous n’êtes pas certain de maîtriser
(notamment en philosophie
ou en économie),
et BANNISSEZ plus généralement
TOUS les termes
que vous n’êtes pas capable
d’utiliser dans une conversation.
Le principe derrière ces deux règles,
c’est que vous ne devez pas compliquer la
problématique
pour impressionner le correcteur.
Vous n’arriverez pas à l’impressionner,
et de toute manière,
votre copie,
il n’en a rien à faire.
Il reste encore deux choses à savoir
pour bien formuler la problématique de la
dissertation.
La première,
c’est qu’elle doit être
une question FERMÉE,
c’est-à-dire qu’elle impose un choix
parmi des réponses préétablies.
Par exemple,
« Quel est le rapport de la philosophie à
la mort ? »
est une question OUVERTE
parce qu’elle ne cadre pas les réponses
possibles.
Cette question favorise
ce que les profs appellent « l’effet catalogue
»,
c’est-à-dire l’empilement d’éléments
de réponse
sans articulation logique.
Avec une question FERMÉE,
on ne peut répondre que « oui »,
« non »,
ou bien une nuance entre les deux
– et les réponses alternatives possibles
poussent à articuler logiquement
les éléments de réponse
dans le plan détaillé.
La dernière chose à savoir
pour formuler la problématique,
c’est une convention
que vous connaissez peut-être déjà :
la problématique doit être DIFFÉRENTE
de l’énoncé.
Du coup,
si le problème intellectuel est transparent
dans l’énoncé,
eh bien il faut le REFORMULER
– ça ne sert pas forcément à grand chose,
mais c’est comme ça.
Maintenant que je vous ai expliqué
les principes pour formuler la problématique
de la dissertation,
voyons ce que ça donne avec mon exemple,
le sujet « Philosopher, est-ce apprendre
à mourir ? ».
Je vous rappelle que le point de départ de
ma réflexion,
c’est que l’hypothèse « philosopher
égale apprendre à mourir »
semble a priori aberrante,
et je vous rappelle
que le problème qui en découle,
c’est de savoir si cette première impression
est pertinente :
est-ce que ça n’a aucun sens de réduire
la philosophie
à l’apprentissage de la mort,
ou bien est-ce qu’il faut creuser l’hypothèse
?
Voici comment j’ai formulé
la problématique de ce sujet de dissertation
:
« La philosophie peut-elle se réduire
à la préparation à la mort ? »
Alors,
vérifions qu’elle a bien les qualités
requises :
elle est bien courte
et claire ;
il n’y a aucun terme technique ;
c’est bien une question FERMÉE ;
et enfin,
elle est différente
de la question de l’énoncé.
Sur le fond,
on retrouve grosso modo
l’hypothèse proposée par le sujet,
mais avec la nuance du point de départ de
ma réflexion :
on comprend bien
en lisant ma problématique
– grâce au verbe « réduire » –
on comprend bien
que l’hypothèse me paraît
de prime abord aberrante.
Voilà,
j’ai trouvé et formulé
la problématique de mon sujet.
Je vous propose maintenant d’essayer à
votre tour
dans les commentaires :
choisissez un sujet de dissertation,
et appliquez PRÉCISÉMENT ma méthode,
avec ses trois étapes,
pour trouver logiquement la problématique.
Je vous dirai ce que j’en pense.
Pour réussir les AUTRES étapes de la dissertation,
et pas seulement la problématisation,
je vous invite à vous inscrire pour recevoir
gratuitement
mon cours de méthodologie
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Si vous avez des questions
sur la problématique de la dissertation,
n’hésitez pas à me les poser dans les
commentaires,
et j’y répondrai sans faute.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous que n’avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête
pour trouver logiquement
la problématique de la dissertation.